what does that mean to you because it
was a heart is this was a tough night
from the beginning night and that's what
I think it was a roller coaster you know
is it really it was painful it's painful
right now it's still painful and we lost
a beloved beloved hero to all of us a
person who is like a true example of
brilliance and excellence and um you
know it's not easy to go forward with
all of that weight but I think that the
energy that he always brought and that
fighting spirit and that that beautiful
uplifting way you know is what brought
us through tonight and I feel like he
was just in all of our hearts and
spirits and that's what made it feel
good so special is that have your boys
here with you so good look at my guys
nice big love to our other son KJ and
Nicole and our beautiful family and it's
such a blessing to be here with our
family encouraging so proud I'm so proud
of a man this is a heavy night and she
put the load on his shoulders and maybe
the people feel comfortable all around
the world
right up right off the back you say one
and done last year you came back this
year do you have another one in you
because I'm what listen you've proven
down that you can do it and you proved
you can do it under crazy circumstance
that's true so y'all don't come back to
me and show me a picture later but
listen I'm honored to be here to
represent the artists represent artistic
community and just for us to continue to
be the light be brilliant be unique be
one-of-a-kind and that's
message so it's a blessed night
[Music]